تنضم إلينا لورا جاريت من سينا
ن بالتفاصيل هنا ، إنها قص
رائعة حقًا للبقاء على قيد الحياة ، كانت هذ
الحالة باردة حتى هذا الأسبوع عن
ما قالت الشرطة إنها حصلت على معلومات حول هذ
الفتاة الصغيرة المحتجزة في من
ل جدها في شمال نيويورك ال
ختطف  في الرابعة من عمرها ، كان الشك في
أن
والديها البيولوجيين أخذوها كما قالت جون لأنهم
كانوا على وشك أن يفقدوا حضانة الشرطة الخاصة بهم
قالوا إنهم ذهبوا بالفعل إلى
المنزل المعني مرارًا وتكرارًا ولكن الجميع
هناك نفوا معرفة أي شيء غير هذا
أسبوعًا كان لديهم أمر تفتيش حقيقي
وبعد تفتيش المنزل لأكثر من
ساعة ، اعتقد أحد الضباط هناك أن
شيئًا ما يبدو في غير محله ،
لكن المحققين قالوا إن هناك
شيئًا غريبًا حول الدرج
بالطريقة التي تم بناؤها بها بالطريقة التي
شعروا بها عندما  كان يمشي عليهم
وقال إنه ألقى نظرة فاحصة
على الدرج وبين اثنين من
ألواح السلم أه هناك صدع استخدم
مصباحًا يدويًا لو  حسنًا هناك ورأى
ما يعتقد أنه بطانية
في الأسفل
لذا استخدموا أداة هالوجين
وبدأوا في إزالة درجات
السلم وبالتأكيد وها وجدوا زوجًا صغيرًا
من الأقدام
تلك الأقدام الصغيرة العارية
للفتاة التي احتفظت بها  مخبأة في هذا الصندوق الذي تراه
تحت الدرج كانت باردة ، كانت
مبللة غير واضح كم من الوقت كانت هناك
تم العثور على والدتها البيولوجية هناك
معها وهكذا
تم الآن القبض على الوالدين والجد جميعًا
وتوجيه الاتهام إليهم ولكن تم
إطلاق سراحهم في وقت لاحق  مع أوامر بالابتعاد عن
هذه الفتاة ، قالت الشرطة إنها
تتمتع بصحة جيدة لكنها أخبرت الضباط أنها
لم تأكل أي شيء منذ فترة ، لذا
توقفوا عند ماكدونالدز في طريقهم
إلى المحطة حيث أخبرتهم أنها
تتذكرها باعتزاز  لقد تم
لم شملها الآن مع أختها الكبرى
وولي أمرها القانوني